ザーッああ
th
質問コーナーでしたはいお待たせいたしました質問コーナーでございますすみません
ちょっと時間がかかりました
質問でゲストたくさんいただきました今回もありがとうございますできれば3応えたい
んですけども
なかなかそういうわけにもいかないので大量のコメントを読むのに時間がかかったり
ちょっといろいろ時間がかかるんですよ僕の質問コーナー
またいつかやろうと思うんで
もし今回も答えてもらえなかったなって人はまた次回ぜひコメントお待ちしております
音の質も中でリクエスト思うんだよね
まあ一人はする人にでは行こうよありのままの自分を見せてください
残念だからし都合はない
[音楽]
はじめの一人暮らし怖くないんですか小人口の新しいにしてから前の背より全然広いん
ですよなので正直すごい寂しいん
部屋が広いとなく寂しく感じるんだよねキリッとして嫌って感じでチェリー
k
パワー no ガー不麻花望むものの道の三木頭に見たいターン童顔とはんだとばーん
わー
アッチ側菓子競い先どこぽつ前ぞみたいだな有馬であーんまり誰ま
だリバティチンチョンん何ですか帰れ大学卒業後にやりたいことは何ですからねいつも
自分の道を行く一さんに勇気をもらっています大学卒業後あった
分進学しようかなと今のところ思っておりますちょっと映像機が学びたいと思っ
頭出す通常になりもう一生筒状とわかった途端楽しさに欠けるシマウマをぐるりと囲む
ように書く人あれああいう名を変える現在の初めは水メットパークの入賞者はあのこの
前注意してからまた一人を着てません
ありがとうございますみんな話すと分かる人なんだよね俺地区何なんですか
何なんですか何なんですよねこっちは何なんです何なんですかから何ですかなんですね
何なんですよ忍者みたいに壁を走ってにっ
こわっちょっと怖い
[音楽]
me
あっあんぱんぷアートパパパップ総合 top 8
そこで止めてスマイル
[音楽]
変えりゃいい歳と0歳の息子に一言おっおおっちょっど全店ねぇどんな
ヌー
翻弄ぶーぶー2 p 2
2 march 0クズバッチぺちゃブーイ
ええええええ
new 例を挙げたままくしゃみできますか
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
今できてたショパンそのことで小指ぶつけてバカでしょ自分でうつけもんじゃない
でしょこれはいきますかいやあー
はぁ本気で怒ってからお前ながらないんでああああああっ
うーん馬鹿にしてるのか足がを口に入れてください
やるわけないかう
おっん
br re
なんでさせた堀田色違いですか大好きですもう版の緊急回避してくださいある以上もう
何な錦鶏たりっていうのスーパーって飛ぶやつでしょ
まじかぁあああ
何か質問テレビクエスト江南店あってね
まあいいでしょ楽しい質問にペーストありがとうございましたまた質問に継承するとき
にちゃんと動画を足すのでぜひまたコメント質問をまずしております
なんか超ハードなんだけど今回じゃあ
新しい版なかった割とでかいのざいましたからね
まあ期間なんでワンパンなんだろうねモテない重すぎて
[拍手]
[音楽]